[Applaudissements]
le Moulin de Saint-Cyr visse ses
derniers instants au de 20 mètres ce
bâtiment emblématique construit en 1932
produisait à l'origine de la farine le
chantier situé à proximité immédiate du
parc du château de Versailles entre dans
sa dernière phase de démolition les
intérieurs de l'édifice ont été abattus
et l'extérieur et désormais grignoté par
des engins mécaniques
c'est la partie plus compliquée c'est ça
ce qu'on est obligé de mettre un tapis
de bémol pour protéger les shoots
pendant des années ce bâtiment était la
source de négociation de non
compréhension à la fois des
Saint-Cyriens à la fois des architectes
des bâtiments de France parce qu'il
venait en fait comme un mur devant la
perspective du château et notamment de
la chambre du roi
accélérer grâce à l'arrivée des Jeux
Olympiques sur Versailles ce projet
accueillera un pôle provisoire pour les
médias à l'été 2024 dès la fin des
épreuves les travaux débuteront pour
créer un parking paysager de 150 places
accessibles en 2025 il permettra plus de
confort et de sécurité pour les
visiteurs du parc du château ces 10
dernières années vous aviez très
régulièrement le long de la RDC des
familles qui venaient qui stationnaient
et vous aviez des enfants qui sortaient
de la voiture sur une RD qui est quand
même assez empruntée la phase de
destruction devrait s'achever d'ici
mi-octobre l'État la Région
Île-de-France Versailles Grand parcs et
le département finance l'ensemble des
travaux de démolition et de construction
estimé à environ 9 millions d'euros